Joe Rogan and Dr Phil have been
spreading the fake news story of
fentanyl candy it is Halloween so it
seems like an appropriate day to do the
story this is one that has become very
popular Donald Trump has been spreading
it at his rallies others have been
repeating it drug dealers are going to
poison and kill your kids by disguising
fentanyl as candy sadly uh it is not
true but it is still being repeated take
a look at this those pills look exactly
like the pills that you get at the
pharmacy and what they're doing now Joe
is they're putting them in these pastel
colors uh and I think I sent you some of
those Jamie uh in the pastel colors
they're making them look like these
candies that the kids get
um and kids are going to see these
things around and pick them up and think
they're like
Sweet Tarts or whatever and bite into
them
um
if if I was a parent
I would go to the store and buy every
kind of candy I could find and as soon
as my kids came home from
trick-or-treating I would take their
pumpkin and dump it into the trash and
then fill it back up with candy I knew
was good and hand it back to them I
wouldn't let them take a single piece of
candy from trick-or-treating because you
don't know what's in there
that was always the fear right when we
were kids so someone was going to sneak
in we thought it would be a razor blade
in an apple or something yeah I saw this
going around but I heard a lot of people
pushing back a couple days after this
yeah Jamie rightly suspects that this
may not be a real story made major
headlines because they were showing them
say no who's the expert I don't I'm just
it there was a lot of uh hubbub about
this viral picture because this went out
the D.A was talking about it but then I
read there was like no evidence that
this was real exactly that's what I read
well let's scroll down and see what they
say in terms of looks like candy DEA
administrator Alan or Ann uh Milgram
told CBS News in fact some of the drug
traffickers have nicknamed It Sweet
Tarts Skittles the DEA alert didn't
mention Halloween but fears about
rainbow Fentanyl and the holiday went
viral
DEA warning meets skepticism from drug
experts drug policy experts contacted by
NPR agree there's no new fentanyl threat
this Halloween many are also skeptical
of the dea's original warning right I
don't believe that Mexican drug cartels
and Street dealers have launched any new
campaign targeting children I don't see
any evidence that the DEA has produced
that supports that conjecture
I don't think they're targeting children
I think the fact that they are making
these things in pastel colors make
children vulnerable to but Dr Phil you
just said they're going to hand these
out at Halloween and you've got to swap
your kids candy
picking these things up yeah you you
want to argue over the the word
targeting
well there's a lot implicit in that word
if a child picks up something where how
that
look you know on the floor drug dealers
are going to leave fentanyl on the on
the ground I said that young girl that I
was talking about took three quarters of
a pill or one quarter of a pill and
three quarters of it was left in her
drawer yeah if she has a a younger
sister right a very specific
hypothetical so let's break this down
why do right-wingers love this story
it's a way to attack Joe Biden that's
that's the origin of this story and you
might say David how on Earth does
fentanyl candy serve as a way to attack
Joe Biden here's how they do it there's
fentanyl in candy
which came in through the Border which
was opened by Joe Biden so fentanyl
candy is Biden's fault and he hates kids
who are going to be poisoned by fentanyl
as they pronounce it uh which is
um uh part of how he doesn't care about
kids now you would think that Rogan
would realize this is the exact same
thing as with the Cannabis Edibles there
was a time as we saw more states
legalize cannabis recreationally
where people said you know a lot of
these Edibles just look like a chocolate
bar it's a very very dangerous kids
aren't going to know they're just going
to say hey chocolate this is good next
thing you know they'll be high as a kite
I'm guessing Rogan rejected that then
because it made no sense but he is not
really applying the same skepticism here
although good for him for at least
looking up an article first of all this
doesn't pass the sniff test the idea
that drug dealers would just dish out
free drugs either as a goof during
trick-or-treating or just would leave
drugs around when the whole point is to
sell the drugs for money doesn't make
any sense drug dealers want to make
money there's no Financial benefit to
dishing out fentanyl laced candy to
Children which might kill them what how
are you making money from that it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever now if
you do some Googling you will find some
stories of drug dealers using candy
packaging
and putting drugs in there and you can
get a resealing machine to make it look
like the Skittles package or whatever
was never open but they're they're not
doing this to then hand out at Halloween
they're just trying to do this to get it
through the Border or authorities or
whatever where police would see it and
say oh it just looks like a package of
Skittles is it hypothetically
theoretically possible that your Skittle
bag that has actually been emptied and
refilled with some kind of drug and then
sealed it could be misplaced and end up
in the hands of a kid sure that's
theoretically possible that's not new I
hate to break it to you but if you
Google what do ecstasy pills look like
MDMA
for decades they have looked like candy
they've got heart-shaped ones and
they've got this that it is not new and
it is not a real thing that kids are
just going oh crazy Sweet Tarts put them
in my mouth
it's a fake story and understand that
the origin is to criticize Biden about
the Border we'll have the clip I played
on our Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show before you go if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description